قراءه عسكريه لما وقع في اليمن من ضربه
امريكيه
بريطانيه محمد دعنا نقول انها من ضمن
الصوره الاقليميه يعني هذه بقعه الشطرنج
الكبيره بدانا
تحريك القطع بشكل سريع اليوم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
توعدت انشات قوه الازدهار او ق حمايه
الازدهار وبالتالي هي قسمت اصلا منطقه
الخليج الى اربع مناطق بحريه الخليج بحر
العرب خليج عدن والبحر الاحمر
فعلت المجموعه 152 في البحر الاحمر
اي اعتبرت رساله ردع المرحله الثانيه هي
منع اطلاق الصواريخ والمسيرات باتجاه
السفن انتقلنا الى المرحله الثالثه مرحله
الفعل لان الردع قد سقط الى حد ما نحن
اليوم في مرحله جديده ماذا سيفعل الحوثيون
ماذا ستفعل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وحلفائها كيف ستتصرف ايران فاذا نحن امام
رمال متحركه حاليا حاليا مرحله جديده
حاليا انتقلنا الى نقطه ال رجعه واللا
عوده طيب في اطار هذه المرحله التي وصفتها
بلا عوده هناك اي تحديث خبري جديد نقلا عن
وزير الدفاع البريطاني الذي يقول بان
اربع مقاتلات تايفون بريطانيه شنت هجمات
على هدفين عسكريين تابعين للحوثيين
بمشاركه قوات امريكيه وكنا قد شاهدنا
الصور التي وردتنا قبل قليل من قبرس والتي
اظهرت اقلاع طائرات تايفون بريطانيه من
هناك اذا نتحدث عن طائرات تيفون نتحدث عن
بوارج حربيه ونتحدث ايضا عن غواصه ما
دلاله استخدام كل هذا التنوع في الادوات
العسكريه
هو عمليه اظهار القوه في استراتيجيه الامن
القومي الامريكي اهم نقطه او من اهم
النقاط هي الملاحه وحريه الملاحه والتجاره
وعدم اغلاق الممرات المائيه في هذه
المنطقه ثلاث ممرات تشكل مثلث
هرمز المندب وقناه السويس اليوم ممنوع ان
ان تغلق
هذه الممرات اليوم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تعتبر نفسها بالاضافه الىى
بريطانيا بالطبع انها تسيطر على البحار في
العالم وهذا الامر قد يضرب الصوره خاصه
انها تتعرض على ما يسمى بمحور المقاومه في
العراق في سوريا اي وحتى يعني في اماكن
اخرى تتعرض لهجمات ومستوى الرد ومستوى
الردع ولكن هذه القدرات الكبيره لقوى عظمى
نتحدث عن جماعه انصار الله الحوثيون الذين
قادرين على خربطت كما يقال اهم ممر من اهم
الممرات المائيه في العالم ولكن باستثمار
قليل ومردود استراتيجي كبير يعني اليوم
نتحدث طائره مسيره عده الاف من الدولارات
مقابل صاروخ معين هل يمكن للغرب وللقوات
هذه ان تستنفر لفترات طويله وتبق قائمه مع
ان لهذا الموضوع بعد اخر يعني تثبيت ال
السيطره البحريه على اهم المعابر لماذا
لانه هذه المنطقه محمد هي تخرج الى ما
يسمى بمنطقه الاندو باسيفيك منطقه الاندو
باسيفيك او منطقه المحيط الهندي والمحيط
الهادي هي مرحله الصراع المستقبلي بين
الصين وبين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع
العلم انه في قاعده جيبوتي هناك قاعده
صينيه الاكبر خارج الصين 500 مليون دولار
يتواجد فيها الفرنسيون الامريك امريكيون
اليابانيون وحتى الصينيون طيب مسؤول
امريكي رفيع صرح وقال بان الضربات الجويه
استهدفت مواقع محدده للحوثيين باستخدام
ذخائر دقيقه هذه العمليه برمتها في تقديرك
هل هي رساله الى الحوثيين للردع او هي
بالفعل استهدفت مواقع من شانها ان تضعف
قدراتهم
العسكريه اولا محمد يسيطر على الارض هو
الذي يسيطر على الحرب او يحدد مجرى الحرب
اليوم عندما نتحدث عن الاسلحه الدقيقه يجب
ان نذهب الى ما يحصل داخل فلسطين المحتله
في غزه عندما تتحدث الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وتضغط على اسرائيل عدم التعرض
للمدنيين والاضرار الجانبيه فاذا هذه صوره
متناسقه مع بعضها اليوم الحوثيون كانوا
ينتظرون هذه الضربه وليس بالضروره ان تضرب
القدرات ان كان من المسيرات او الصواريخ
او الصواريخ المضاده للسفن وحتى قد يكون
هناك الغام بحريه ال المهم اليوم حتى ولو
ضربت قدرات معينه يكفي ان يكون هناك مسيره
بعد يوم او يومين على سفينه تج هذا صدد
عميد الياس ليغير في هذا الصدد عميد الياس
المسؤول الامريكا الرفيع يقول لم نرصد حتى
الان اي رد للحوثيين على ضربات سواء
بالبحر الاحمر وباب المندب او خليج عدن هل
تتوقع ردا حوثيا
سريعا ليس بالضروره ان يكون سريع يعني
اليوم نتحدث عن عمليه طويله الامد كما قلت
اليوم الحوثيون يستعملون حتى ولو كان من
يتهمهم انهم مع ايران وهذه لعبه جيو
سياسيه هذا الامر ليس بالضروره من الاتهام
انهم باستثمار قليل يضعون نفسهم في معادله
كبيره جدا على الصعيد العالمي وليس
بالضروره ان يرد اليوم الحوثي لماذا لانه
اليوم الاستنفار الغربي استنفار كبير جدا
ومرتفع اي تحرك الحوثي سوف يرصد و ستبقى
وستصبح مناطق الحوثيين منطقه اهتمام اساسي
اي مراقبه 24 على 24
من الاقمار الاصطناعيه من المسيرات او ما
شابه فاذا الرد دائما هو رد لا تماثلي او
ما يسمى بالانجليزيه اسمتك يعني انت تنتظر
لترصد نقاط الضعف لدى الاخر
وبالتالي تنفذ شيء معين هذا التنفيذ له
مردود استراتيجي يعني اليوم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه مع بريطانيا في اقصى
درجات الاستنفار والضرب بعد جمعه بعد
اسبوع او يومين او ثلاثه يكفي عمل حوثي
واحد بسيط غير مكلف ليغير كل المعادله هذه
ميازين القوى صعبه جدا في هذه المعركه ja